Oars, the ancient giant, was Joyboy. This
is one of the most popular and crazy sounding
one piece theories in existence. So i sat
down for the last 48 hours straight, and gathered
all the evidence I could find on the internet
to see if its plausible. And I ended up going
down a rabbit hole so deep, it made me question
everything I thought I had known about One
Piece, especially with recent events in the
manga. Here’s what I found.
Starting with what we know for a fact about
the mysterious figure Joy Boy and the even
more mysterious race of ancient giants in
One Piece. We know that Joyboy lived about
800 years ago, around the time of the Void
Century. We know that he had a promise with
Fishman Island that he would raise the Noah
with the help of Poseidon, but for an unknown
reason that promise was broken.
We also know that Joyboy was a companion of
Zunesha.
At some point, Joyboy also left an unimaginable
treasure behind at the end of the Grand Line
- a treasure now known as the One Piece.
Joyboy also proclaimed on the poneglyphs that
he would return in 800 years’ time. Enter
Luffy, who upon unlocking Gear 5th for the
first time, was proclaimed by Zunesha to be
the second coming of Joyboy.
But wait…if we’re talking about Oars being
Joyboy…some of you are probably already
thinking about a potential problem. If we
look back to Thriller Bark, it’s stated
that Oars died around 500 years ago. Morai
found him frozen in the land of ice.
Now, I’m no mathematician but 800 and 500
are two different numbers. Doesn’t that
throw a wrench into this whole theory already?
Well, no.
there are 2 reasons for this: First: As we’ll
discuss in more detail, there are actually
2 candidates for Joy Boy. One is the oars
that Luffy fought on Thriller bark. We know
that regular giants have crazy long lifespans.
After all, Dorry and Broggy were casually
dueling for 100 years. Ancient Giants, who
are multiple times taller than regular giants
could have an even *longer* lifespan.
Also with the ice preserving Oars’ tissue,
the dating could just be wrong, making his
death look more recent than it actually was.
However, let’s say Oars lived around the
time the explorer Nolan lived in One Piece.
It could also have been Oars’ ancestor.
Oars Junior is Oars the 3rd. That means there
was an Oars the second. The giant Skull on
Onigashima has a good chance to be related
to Oars as well. This could make Moria’s
Oars the II and this one Oars the I, and therefore
JoyBoy. We’ll get to that in just a second.
But i want to stick with the frozen-in-Ice-thing
for a moment. Because it is one of the themes
that unites all ancient giants in the story.
When Moria dug up Oars, he was frozen in ice
- but this is far from the only frozen giant
we’ve seen in the series. In Punk Hazard
there were a bunch of frozen preserved giants.
The Yeti Cool brothers were some icy giants
also on Punk Hazard.
The man who froze half of Punk Hazard, Aokiji,
froze one of our favorite giants on Ohara-
Jaguar D. Saul. And he also froze the new
Joy Boy Luffy. And in a giant freezer in Mariejois,
Imu keeps a giant frozen straw hat. One that
happens to be appropriately Oars sized. The
straw hat by the way, is the second thing
ancient giants seem to share. Next to the
giant one in Marijois, you have the Yeti Cool
brothers wearing straw hats, just like Luffy,
Saul wore a hat, Oars Junior got a straw hat
from ace and as we know, Moria’s oars was
looking for a straw hat as well.
Now these are all facts that we have seen
in the story. But this was just the first
of 5 levels that I discovered. This goes much
much deeper And the last level is a theory
so insane, that if true would change one piece
forever as we know it.
So let’s look at the core of this theory:
Are there actually signs or even better evidence,
that Ors was Joy Boy, Luffy’s predecessor.
Simply from a power perspective, Oars seems
to definitely qualify for the role of JoyBoy.
You probably remember, that Moria once challenged
and got defeated by Kaido in Wano, when he
was still a Rookie. That’s when he took
Ryuma’s body to turn him into a Zombie.
And Moria had still not given up on becoming
Pirate King and challenging the Yoko. He thought
that with Oars’ zombie, even if not with
the full strength of the original, he could
defeat Kaido. Moria has the bodies of people
like Ryuma and Captain Jon, one of the former
Rocks Pirates and still, his master piece
to become pirate king was Oars. He clearly
knew exactly whom he had pulled out of the
ice there. And so did the government.
Zoro’s sacrifice for Luffy and the crew
as well as the battle at Marineford were 2
such incredibly epic moments, that Eiichiro
Oda got to sneak in a very important detail,
pretty much unnoticed: The government tried
to assassinate Moria, not just once, but twice
after they found out that he has recovered
oars. First they sent Kuma and then during
the war at marineford, someone ‘above the
marines’ ordered Doflamingo to take Moria
out. Now there are really not that many people
who could do that. It was either Imu himself
or the Gorosei. An order from the highest
level. The 5 elders and Imu of course know
about Joy Boy and the void century. They have
worked hard to eradicate any evidence of his
existence or his powers from history. Just
remember how they tried to hunt and discredit
joy boy’s Nika fruit, that was ultimately
stolen by Shanks and eaten by Luffy.
Meanwhile, the government themselves want
to create an army of ancient giants as well.
As Law explains to us, it would be their ultimate
and unbeatable weapon. The same is true for
Big Mom and Kaido, both of whom know about
Joy Boy. Just remember the giant kids from
punk hazard, as well as the numbers. Kaido,
who himself has strong Oni features, believed
himself to be Joy Boy for a while, before
he started looking for someone else who could
fill that role.
Blackbeard and Rocks, two people who most
likely also know more about the true history
than most others might know about Oar’s
significance as well. Blackbeard’s jolly
roger are 3 skulls, and 3 skulls can also
be found on both Oars and Oars Jr’s belt.
meanwhile, Rocks’ jolly roger, is a skull
with hors. Could be a coincidence and maybe
it means something completely different. We
really don’t know yet.
We also know that Oars was actively painted
as evil. He is described as the cruel giant
called the continent puller. That’s because
Legend has it that he amassed countries and
islands under his control and his band of
villains. Now, it’s very plausible that
Oars was a terrible monster. But there is
also a decent chance that things might not
be what they seem here. We do know that the
world government is the Marie Kondo of changing
people’s history and true nature. Does ithis
person inspire love and hope in you? Defame
them. Call them a devil. Get creative and
extinguish the spark of joy for anyone who
tries to rise up against you. Oars being called
a devil goes very well with what we know from
Nico Robin. And the devil, as you know is
the enemy of god. Now there is a whole lot
of symbolism around the giants and the devil,
that I won’t get into too much here. Saul’s
biblical name, devil fruits, Adam and eve
tree, you get it. The devils in one piece
are the good guys. As for the continent pulling,
this hasn’t been officially confirmed, but
it seems pretty clear that Wano is the result
of just that. It’s a mix of different islands
with different climates pulled together, possibly
so that different people and races from across
the world could live there in peace and safety
together. If you remember, Toki, who travelled
into this time period from the Void century
and who is part of the wano clans and culture
did not actually know where wano was and was
looking for it. The simple explanation here
could be, that wano as a place simply didn’t
exist yet. Maybe JoyBoy told her of his plans
to create the island ‘wano’ and told her
to go look for it. This of course goes hand
in hand perfectly with the gargantuan skull
located right in front of Wano. Possibly Oar’s
ancestor who died after pulling the islands
together.
We do know that Zunesha was Joy Boy’s companion,
which would make sense size wise. And Zunesha
heard Joy boy’s return as Luffy awakened
his fruit on top of the gigantic skull. The
same skull, that Kaido, who was obsessed with
Joy Boy’s return, made his headquarters.
Now, we have gotten no confirmation yet if
that giant creature was actually alive at
some point, nor who it was. So this could
all just be a bit of a red herring Oda is
throwing us.
Let’s go another Level deeper.
According to most theories, the main piece
of evidence for one version of Oars being
Joy Boy, is Oar’s supposed parallels and
connections with Luffy during Thriller Bark.
Well, first off, he gets Luffy’s shadow.
Just like Luffy is the 2nd coming of Joyboy,
Luffy and Oars have a direct link. And he
does behave exactly like Luffy. However isn’t
that explained by Luffy’s shadow being inside
him? After all the zombies do take on parts
of the personality from the shadow they are
infused with. Well there could be an explanation
for that.
Other shadow zombies seem to be in conflict
between the shadow personality and the body’s
original personality. For example, Ryuma’s
original personality and Brook’s shadow
seem to be vying for control.
However, Oars is immediately acting like Luffy
and there’s never another sign of any personality
besides that. We could see that as him adopting
Luffy’s personality, but it could also be
that Luffy and the original Oars were more
alike than we would initially expect.
We also see Oars attempt to put on a straw
hat. He doesn’t find a giant straw hat,
but he does make do temporarily with a piece
of building. Again, this could be interpreted
as Luffy’s personality looking for his signature
Straw Hat, but we’ve seen a giant Straw
Hat beneath Mariejois that would be a perfect
fit for this Ancient Giant.
Moreover, when Oars attempts to use Gomu-Gomu
techniques…the zombie actually stretches.
The reasoning we get within the arc is that
the body is just following the shadow. But
is that actually what’s happening? What
if Oars’ body already had rubber properties
because he already had Luffy’s devil fruit
while he was alive? This is something we can
only speculate on for right now. We don’t
have any other cases of a zombie with a devil
fruit power besides Brook’s and that one
isn’t exactly applicable because it’s
a special case. In addition, we haven’t
been able to see whether the body of a devil
fruit user maintains properties of its fruit.
Would Luffy’s body stay rubbery after death
or would it revert back to normal once the
fruit reincarnates?
Oars being already stretchy, instead of suddenly
gaining devil fruit abilities through Moria’s
power is certainly less of a *stretch* than
Luffy’s shadow influencing the corpse to
that degree. otherwise Moria has one of the
most powerful fruits of all time, being able
to clone abilities.
Also, speaking of stretches…this is a real
reach, but if you look at the swirly patch
on Oars’ belly, it even kind of resembles
the pattern of the Gomu-Gomu no Mi.
And let me throw in another few more random
pieces of evidence here: Like Oda making meat
Oar’s favorite food. Or that Oars says that
Luffy is his enemy and introduces himself,
when Sanji addresses him as Luffy. So he seems
to be aware of who he is, just like Ryuma.
And on the cover for volume 48 showing oars
and Luffy in the same pose with oars teeth
giving Luffy horns. Now, could this be more
evidence for the theory? I mean, I guess it
makes sense, but these could all also be explained
differently or as coincidences.
So let’s give Moria the benefit of the doubt.
Maybe he really has the most ridiculous fruit
in the world. Maybe Oars is simply so much
like Luffy, because Luffy’s shadow is just
that powerful. I personally even think that
this Oars was not Joy Boy at all. It could
well have been foreshadowing for A version
of oars being Joy Boy. Because the gargantuan
skull on Onigashima is still my favorite candidate.
If anything, Thriller bark might have been
more of a giant hint for the real joyboy and
what he was like. Which was most likely, a
lot llike Luffy.
Now Luffy is already confirmed to be Joy Boy,
and we also have seen Luffy turn into a giant
at more than one occasion. Different versions
of gear 5, but in particular his giant form
during his awakening, that allowed him to
beat Kaido. That fist was the size of onigashima,
which would have been the right size of the
creature, who’s skull we see there. Since
Moria was convinced Oars could defeat Kaido,
maybe he was right about that and foreshadowed
this moment. It’s also that giant fist that
makes Kaido see Luffy as Joy Boy as well before
he is obliterated.
So let’s say we push aside oars on Thriller
bark for a second here as a candidate for
Joy Boy. Who were these giga giants, like
the skull in Onigashima or on Punk Hazard?
And where did they go?
Let’s go down another level. This is where
things get super juicy.
But first, if you have enjoyed this video
so far and made it to the final level, make
sure to subscribe for more content like this.
I have a ton of awesome stuff like this coming
up.
Now, Oars and Oars Jr are already the largest
giants in One Piece. But they dwarf in comparison
with these two skulls. The numbers, who are
failed attempts to make ancient giants, easily
fit inside the giant skull dome to party there.
But as we know, these creatures aren’t the
only enormous things in the One Piece world.
You have giant elephants, seakings, goldfish,
trees, gates. even the tower of Impel Down,
which reaches from the bottom of the ocean
to the surface is up to 10km tall. For comparison
the largest building on earth right now is
the Burj Khalif. And it’s ‘only’ 828-meters
tall. In other words: Impel down is 12 times
taller than the tallest building humanity
has ever built.
But clearly, the giant things from the past
have gotten smaller and smaller. Ancient giants
are getting smaller with each generation,
as are normal giants and even humans. Now
this phenomenon exists in our world too. There
were actual hobbit people and small elephants
that evolved due to something called Island
dwarfism. It’s an evolutionary process that
reduced body size when a large animal is limited
to a small environment, primarily islands.
Which, woopty doo, look at that, is just what
we have in One PIece.
Could it be, that the once piece world once
had much much more land for these giant creatures
to evolve? The one piece world DOES look incredibly
artificial after all, and we have just gotten
confirmation from the manga, that One Piece
takes place in a post apocalyptical world,
that used to have advanced technology. There
is Pangea castle on top of the red line, the
only continent in the world. Pangea was the
name of the super continent that we once had
on earth. And the by now infamous globe on
Ohara with multiple moons also shows something
that could be the red line, but with many
larger land masses butted up against it, that
clearly don’t exist anymore.
Could Oda have been inspired by the flood
myth, that exists in pretty much every culture
in our world as well? Was the world of one
piece flooded until only islands remained?
There might be some hints. Most obvious of
all is of course the literal arc noah, an
ancient ship large enough to carry an entire
civilization. You have curious underwater
structures all throughout one piece. The giant
whirlpool and the hole under enies lobbie.
Placed directly next to these enormous gates,
larger than anything in one piece, that also
reach down all the way to the bottom of the
ocean. Next to it, Impel Down, a tower that
looks like a defense tower with places to
stand outside and potentially harbouring a
whole nation if under attack from a major
enemy. It also is build from the bottom up,
not the other way around. Places like Alubana
are curiously placed on top of a tall plateau.
And in Wano we have already seen an entire
ancient world sunken underneath the water.
But what on earth could do this? Well, now
that we know of the futuristic technology
that existed in one piece before the void
century, it’s not that hard to imagine really.
The ancient kingdom was probably even more
advanced than humanity is in our world with
giant robots and space travel. So if we have
the potential to destroy our planet, they
surely had too.
In One Piece,Uranusnamed after the greek
god of the sky, is said to possess power enough
to destroy whole worlds. Not islands. Worlds.
And this is stated as a matter of fact in
One Piece, even by people like people as scientific
as Robin. How do people know what Uranus is
capable of? Well, Because its power HAS been
witnessed before.
It might well be that the ancient weapon Uranus
has been used not only once, but twice before.
History repeating itself. For all we know,
there is not only the void century in One
PIece, but a whole pre-pre history before
it. Places like Arubana date back 4000 years
ago. The adam tree 5000 years. This is before
the ancient kingdom. It could well have been
the age of the person known as Nika, though
this truly is speculation now. So let’s
set this aside. Matter of fact is, there are
signs throughout the world of One piece, that
a cataclysmic flood occurred that created
a world of islands, with the rulers or gods
of the world, whether its the Lunarians or
the celstial dragons, living on top of the
red line, far out of reach.
But we’re not done yet. Let’s go to that
final, crazy level, that brings this all the
way back to Oars. Yes, I haven’t forgotten
what this video is all about.
Now, since we’re already in the land of
speculation now. Let me start with the premise.
What if Uranus was not a weapon used by the
ancient kingdom, as is commonly assumed for
some reason, but against it? Let me introduce:
The titan myth. The person who came up with
this really deserves a medal of sorts. In
case you are not super familiar with greek
mythology. The Gods, like Zeus, Pluton, Poseidon
or Uranus, were not the first rules of the
world. It was actually the titans. After defeating
the Titans, the Gods banished them to Tartarus,
to hell, and built their castle on mount olympus.
This would very nicely combine both the abrahamic
influences of the flood, adam and eve and
the devil with the greek creation myth. Tartarus
and Hades are not the same thing by the way.
Hades is hell. Tartarus, accroding to Zeus
is as far beneath hades as heaving is above
earth.
Also, i want to note, that not all the Titans'
were Titan in size. Some were human size.
And of course, the Titans are the Natural
Enemy of the gods.
Now, doesn’t this all fit in very very nicely
with all of One PIece. Surrounding the 3 gates
of justice, bigger than anything else in the
story, that could represent the locking away
of the titans, we have the island of Justice
(Enies Lobby), the island of punishment (Impel
Down), and the island of Death (Marine Head
Quarters). All three together form hell. Enies
Lobby has the three headed Cerberus through
the three headed guardianBaskerville. Impel
Downis modeled after dante’s hell even
includingFiddler's Greenas Newkama Land.
And War is considered to be the best representation
of "Hell on Earth". We experience it in Marineford
which was luffy’s personal hell.
Could the 3 gates of justice and the giant
whirlpool trap the titans, the oni race, at
the bottom of the ocean? Which would also
fit very well with the idea of Laugh Tale
being down there. Does Luffy’s journey,
like so many other heroes, take him over the
edge of the world to the bottom of the sea?
To free the oni race, so that the titans,
the original inhabitants of one piece, can
walk the earth once again.
This would also fit in perfectly with the
reveal of the ancient kingdoms adavanced techonology.
The titans, like Oars aka Joy Boy, would have
been the inhabitants of this great kingdom.
If you are curious about that reveal by the
way and what it means, i broke it all down
for you in this video right here.